hello collectors this is Jake from Geek
culture and this time we are back at
collector's Arc to take a look at some
of the coolest Collectibles that you can
get out there and this time around it's
2019's Joaquin Phoenix Jokers statue and
bus in our first unboxing and review of
these cool items that will be on show
soon so stay tuned
So today we're going to look at two
pieces by Queen Studios the first will
be this life-size Joker bus with only
199 out there in the world you know this
thing is going to be a sweet collectible
for your collection so let's take a look
right now
and there we have it auto flag otherwise
known as the Joker from the 2019 film so
we're gonna look at this life-size bus
from Queen studios in detail so we have
that very very beautiful rooted hair
right here that iconic green then we go
down to the Silicon face with the iconic
Joker makeup as well and then we have
his very very nice looking suit you know
something that you and I probably won't
be able to rock on a day-to-day basis
and if you thought this life-size
Joaquin Phoenix Joker bus couldn't get
any better let me show you something
it lights up and from the front you can
see that recognizable silhouette of
Joker doing his dance on top of the
Bronx staircase and then if we go to the
back
you have outer flag doing his makeup as
well as our very own Xeno doing his
makeup as with all statues and bus the
devil's in the details so let's take a
look what's behind the utter flight bus
get this You Look Marvelous back hanging
over here broken light bulbs around the
mirror just you know to showcase the
conditions that other flag is working in
got a few nice little post Cuts here
calling back to the movie of course you
have Joker himself you know applying
makeup for his one last show and all the
different kind of materials that he has
to work with on the table and if you're
taking a look at the Cameo just now by
Xeno you know that Queen Studios has
helpfully provided this powder just for
you to touch up Joker's makeup when it
looks a little bit off color and of
course like with all Queen studio stuff
you get this nice brush as well to get
rid of all the dust and whatnot if you
want your statues looking good
you'll be all right just look at those
beautiful eyes that you have so full of
sorrow and purpose and you should take a
look at his eyes as well look at how
well constructed they are and going up
we've got those nice Paws this very nice
bone structure and of course that rooted
hair that make it seem so real so that's
all for this lifestyle bus let's move on
to the next statue let's get this big
open oh my God
it's quite tight
oh you're right so just like many of
Queen Studios other offerings they put a
lot of work into the details including
lighting now everything you see on this
makeup table can be placed according to
your own ones and needs if you want to
make a mess just like autoflex will do
you can go ahead and do that so now
we're going to take a look at him Joker
himself there's one third skill deluxe
edition of The artiflex Statue get his
nice
cigarette in his hand you know tracking
the iconic post but what's most
important is this hit scalp with rooted
hair we're not looking at sculpted hair
here we're looking at rooted hair then
you can move around and it almost feels
like the real thing as if he has not
showered for days without the smell
thankfully then we're going to go down
into the suit just like the bus you can
see that kind of same suit that he has
on here it all feels real nice you can
flare it out show off a little bit the
chair that he's sitting on is real solid
unfortunately it doesn't move but it's
okay because it has his arm here so it's
there for support all the way down to
his feet where you have real cotton
socks stretchy there right there and
then his shoes and shoelaces so now if
you are a big fan of Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker then this one to scale replica of
outer flag in its natural setting in his
makeup room in front of the mirror it's
perfect for your collection now if you
can get this in your home you're sure to
put on a happy face every time you see
this and there you have it this is our
intimate look at Queen Studios life-size
Joker bus as well as The Wanted skill
deluxe edition Joker set now from what
we have seen so far from the details on
the makeup table all the way to the base
of this life size bus we know that Queen
Studios has once again outdone
themselves and these pieces will make
perfect additions to any Ruby collectors
who love Batman and especially the joker
now all this wouldn't be possible it
wasn't for the help of collectors Arc if
you are collector of Premium statues and
collectibles from licenses such as
Marvel DC Lord of the Rings and more be
sure to check them out on all the social
media platforms including the Joker's
favorite one Facebook and that's it for
today's video now remember if any
questions for this life-size bus all
this wanted skill statue replica of the
Joker be sure to hit us up in the
comments below as usual give us a like
subscribe and stay tuned to even more
interesting content coming your way from
Geek culture this is Jake and I'm off to
put on a happy face